[Music]
on this Sunday night cut off from the
outside
world the communications blackout in
Gaza as Israel intensifies its
retaliation the nightmare scenario for
civilians after a blast at a refugee
camp in a declared safe Zone plus
hundreds of Canadians stuck inside Gaza
waiting to get out Hamas said they
wanted to have a number of people of
interest to cross the
[Music]
border thousands of workers set to hit
the picket lines in Quebec what it means
for schools and healthc care services
starting tomorrow plus PanAm gold the
Canadian break dancing his way to the
Olympics global national with bar
Asser each day more suffering more death
death and Destruction for gazin
civilians today a blast leveled the
elmazi refugee camp a day after a un
School housing displaced Palestinian
children was hit the camp is located in
a region the Israeli Defense Force urged
Palestinians to seek Refuge as it
focused its pressure in the north gaza's
Hamas run Health Ministry says at least
45 people have been killed many of whom
are women and children and claims the
blast was from an Israeli air strike
Israel says it's investigating but says
strikes on Hamas Targets in Gaza are
based on
intelligence shelling also hit near the
AL coulds Hospital in Gaza City today
where gazans are Sheltering trying to
escape the Bloodshed and the tragic
realities of Israel's war against
Hamas good evening and thank you for
joining us Gaza once again is under a
communication's blackout the third since
Israel's War began the outage confirmed
by Palestinian tele company palel has
made it even more complicated to share
details of what Israel is calling a
significant stage of its military
offensive Israel says it's encircled
Gaza City and it's split The Enclave
into two North and South Israeli PLS
once again dropped leaflets urging
Palestinians to move South but the UN
has said there is no place safe in Gaza
right now according to Global Affairs
Canada more than 400 Canadian citizens
are trying to get out of Gaza and cross
into to Egypt but that is yet to happen
Global Affairs Canada is aware of three
Canadians who did manage to cross the
border through a third party but one
exactly that was and how is unclear
Danielle Haman is in Jerusalem she
begins our coverage tonight but first a
warning that some of the images you're
about to see are quite
disturbing this was supposed to be saham
bat nei's ticket out of Gaza today 200
Canadian passport holders including her
Young young daughter were meant to cross
into Egypt Instead This is what the Rafa
border looked like at a complete
standstill no one allowed to
leave death haunts us every second she
says why can't countries around the
world see us as humans daily trips to
Rafa has meant dodging air strikes and
praying their Journey there would be the
last Canadian Asia Mur gave us an update
the moment she received one I just got a
call from Global Affairs telling us that
they will call us if there anything
changes for now everything is closed
borders will remain closed till further
notice and she told me this time it
might take longer to get us out a team
of Canadians is ready to receive them on
the other side but no one knows exactly
when that will be what's the reason you
were given for the holdup today the
holdup today is essentially a a
disagreement between the different
parties where namely uh
Israel Egypt and uh Hamas to the effect
that uh Hamas wanted to have a certain
number of individuals cross into Egypt
to get medical attention to which the
Israelis and the Egyptians have refused
so and Hamas essentially said if these
individuals that who are of interest to
habas cannot go through then nobody
through Egyptian citizens are begging
their president to open the Border this
woman says she lived in the magazi camp
in central Gaza this is what's left of
it
now they hit the water tank as they did
with all the other water tanks did the
water tanks throw stones at them did the
water tanks fire a rocket he asks they
are doing this to humiliate
people as the strikes on Gaza by air sea
and ground continue for Benjamin
Netanyahu any talk of a ceasefire is
still out of the
question there won't be a ceasefire
without the return of our hostages he
said some Israeli ministers believe
Netanyahu is not going hard enough on
Gaza no such thing as an innocent
Palestinian is what the farri Heritage
Minister amihai ilahu said in fact he
went even further suggesting that a
nuclear attack on Gaza could be an
option he's since been
suspended far Danielle Hamin in
Jerusalem tonight thank you Danielle a
day after meeting with foreign ministers
from Arab states the US Secretary of
State made a surprised visit to the West
Bank today to meet Palestinian Authority
president Mahmud Abbas as David Aken
reports the two leaders explored ways to
ease civilian suffering in the Gaza
Strip and what role the Palestinian
Authority might play in a postconflict
scenario in Gaza and a warning some of
this footage is also
disturbing US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin left Israel Sunday morning for
an unannounced visit to the West Bank
City of rala and a meeting under heavy
security with Palestinian Authority
president mmud abas neither leader made
any comments to reporters at the time
but later during a stop in Iraq blinkin
said he told a boss he expects the
Palestinian Authority to play a central
role in the future of the Gaza Strip
although just how that might happen was
not made clear with regard to uh future
Gaza the West Bank Palestinian views
Palestinian voices uh Palestinian
aspirations need to be at the center of
that um and that's what uh that we we
focused on blink's visit to the West
Bank came on the same day Israeli forces
raided several towns in the West Bank
blowing up one house and bulld doing
others according to Residents one of
America's top priorities is also the top
priority of Israel and many other
Western allies including Canada the
release of those taken captive by Hamas
on October 7th working for the release
of over 200 hostages including Americans
will remain a top priority until their
captivity comes to an
end Israeli TV continues to show moments
like this when Jewish hostages were
taken this video obtained by Reuters
shows 19-year-old nahama Shahar shortly
after she was
captured shahar's mother was among those
who took part in a rally in Tel Aviv
Saturday demanding the return of
hostages oh I just want this all to be
over I don't want to speak to cameras
anymore I don't want to be in crowds I
just want to be back home and and have
Nama back home that's it you know I have
nothing more to add it's so simple
blink's next next meeting in the region
will be in Turkey on Sunday Turkish
president tup erdogan spoke at a rally
near the Black
Sea erdogan promised to quote grab the
cers end quote of those killing
Palestinians and vowed that turkey would
save Palestinians from what he called
quote Israeli cruelty David Aken Global
News while Pro Palestinian rallies all
over Canada have been largely peaceful
Ottawa Police are investig getting
reports of a man with a sign displaying
a swastika in an Israeli flag after
someone at the rally snapped a photo of
him and shared it on social
media though the image and text in the
sign is blurry it does appear to show
Israel's flag next to the Nazi symbol
the photo was has drawn widespread
condemnation from politicians across the
political Spectrum including the Prime
Minister the conflict in the Middle East
has sparked protests around the world
for weeks some of those demonstrations
are leading to violence and in the US
emotions are spilling over into college
campuses Jennifer Johnson looks at how
the Bloodshed between Israel and Hamas
is becoming a flash point for
postsecondary school
students Cornell University shut down
Friday after a college junior Patrick Dy
was charged with making violent
anti-semitic threats including killing
Jews on campus the FBI is investigating
this is a threat that is uh reaching in
some way sort of historic levels the
Jewish Community uh is targeted by
terrorists really across the Spectrum as
the conflict between Israel and Hamas in
Gaza rages on anti-semitic and
anti-muslim incidents are surging but
few expected the increase to affect so
many college campuses at a pro
Palestinian protest near tulan
University at least two students were
assaulted after a flag burning led to
fist fights an Israeli flag was being
burned and a brave two-lane student
attempted to grab the flag before a
fight broke out the Biden admin
Administration is denouncing what it
calls an alarming rise in anti-Semitism
across the country we can't stand by and
stand silent in the face of hate we must
without equivocation denounce
anti-Semitism some students say they
feel more vulnerable than ever and are
taking no chances you know I don't wear
anything that would show My Religion
just because you just don't know how
people are going to react pro-israel
supporters held solidarity walks at
seven Georgia universities this week
asking administrators to do more to
protect them students are afraid to be
themselves where they go to school and
that should never be the case and it's
not just Jewish students fearing for
their lives Columbia University has set
up a task force after trucks circled the
campus displaying names and photos of
Arab Muslim and Palestinian students
College administrators are asking
students on both sides to show more
understanding for students they will
remember this um and they will remember
what they learned from from it and what
they learned about their ability to come
together as part of it but as the
conflict rages on tensions continue to
flare putting millions of students on
edge Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington as Russia's war in Ukraine
rages on Ukrainian president vomir
zalinsky weighed in on the crisis
gripping the Middle East in an interview
with NBC news zilinsky also accused
Moscow of playing a role in the conflict
as sponsors of
Hamas and some people are still throwing
matches into this fire and I'm I'm sure
that Russia was behind and sponsoring
Hamas and Iran too that's who is to
blame you have to admit that these
countries are Behind These processes and
I would also add North Korea sininsky
also adds that while Israel has every
right to defend itself the world should
also focus on opening humanitarian
corridors and doing all it can to stop
the conflict but he also acknowledged
Israel's war against Hamas was drawn
drawing attention away from Russia's
Invasion and critical resources from
Western allies like the US he says
support for Ukraine's defense remains
key to Europe's
stability in Nepal the search for
survivors has been called off two days
after a powerful earthquake devastated a
remote region in the country's
West more than 150 people died and
hundreds of buildings were destroyed
when the 5.6 magnitude Quake hit Friday
according to reports official have now
shifted their focus to providing Aid to
survivors who lost their homes
authorities are having difficulty
reaching affected areas because of the
mountainous terrain and the landslides
that are now blocking the roads
thousands of Quebec public sector
workers set to hit the picket lines
coming up how the labor dispute could
escalate if negotiations continue to
drag
on Quebec is Racing for a major strike
starting Monday morning more than
400,000 public sector workers will be on
the picket line all under the banner of
the common front it's a collection of
four different unions representing
employees in the Education Health and
Social Services sectors demanding better
wages and working conditions it's
expected to be the largest mobilization
since it was founded 50 years ago
Felicia Perillo
reports nearly half a million Quebec
public sector workers will be off the JW
Monday morning the common front made up
of four different Union federations are
demanding better wages and working
conditions after negotiations that have
been dragging on for months kind of SLA
our in our face right now one of the
Union vice presidents says the common
front is asking for annual increases
tied to the inflation rate but the
government's latest offer which was
quickly rejected was a 10.3% increase
over 5 years meaning workers are
effectively being offered a pay cut they
have money to send some check to all the
quiers before the election and when is a
time to pay this the staff the uh the
the workers from the public sector they
have no money the government however
says the offer was a reasonable one we
think that our offer is the best to help
improving services to
quebecers workers say they feel like the
government is out of touch with what's
happening on the ground employees are
overworked underpaid and the general
public suffers as a result I think a
lack of awareness or lack of a reality
check on on how students are actually
needing much more services than we are
able to provide and uh we just don't
have the Personnel these issues are
things Canadians can relate to says Mill
sociology Professor Barry idin he says
the strike resonates with quebecers I
think there's a direct connection that
people can make
between both the fact that what they're
fighting for is is are issues that
affect other Canadians but also the
connection that you know if we value
quality Public Services a key aspect of
quality Public Services is a
well-treated public sector Workforce the
common front says if the government
doesn't get serious about negotiations
it'll hold another strike in a few weeks
meanwhile Fick the largest nurses Union
in the province is expected to walk off
the job on Wednesday and Thursday
another 65,000 Quebec teachers have also
voted for a general strike on November
23rd Felicia pillo Global
newsreal testing the wat is ahead how
researchers are using pandemic era
methods for new studies on our
waterways
at the height of the pandemic testing
for waste water for Co 19 became a great
way to track how much virus was
circulating in specific communities now
Canadian researchers are using the same
methods to test freshwater in Nova
Scotia where they've recently discovered
Co and other human viruses in the
province's Great Lakes Heidi petk looks
at how that Discovery is creating hope
for safer water down the
road in a city known for its Lakes this
floating plastic sphere no bigger than a
baseball led to a surprising discovery
for researchers about what's in the
water we found uh RSV we found influenza
we found SARS that includes SARS K2 the
virus responsible for the co 19 pandemic
their findings after testing several
Halifax area lakes now published in
scientific reports the results so novel
the study's authors can't answer yet
what it means for anyone wanting to take
a dip in a lake although the who has
said coid 19 doesn't transmit through
water right now I couldn't really say
like this is safe or not safe because we
don't have a lot of benchmarks is this
uh normal or abnormal we we don't really
know there isn't really any literature
like this out there that's exciting
though you know we we can hopefully use
this to try to understand
more for haze these are the key to that
understanding each ball holds a small
bag of activated carbon which soaks up
water and the viruses in it which is
later extracted and measured she came up
with the design 2 years ago after
brainstorming ways to measure coid 19 in
Wastewater the sewers can be quite
aggressive sometimes with the flow so I
wanted something that could easily
bounce around and and not be easily
damaged so the the ball served to to do
that well and then it allows um us to
easily deploy our absorbent material
without you know fouling the the
membrane we would deploy um Samplers at
various locations weekly um and kind of
bring them back to the lab and then I
would analyze them the researchers hope
this small ball will make a big impact
when it comes to testing fresh water not
just here but around the world this tool
far easier to use than traditional
testing methods which can require
collecting up to 1,500 lers of water at
a time and so several are making their
way to other scientists searching for
pathogens in bodies of water South of
the Border and in Africa water important
to in so many parts of our Lives an
innovation they hope will someday mean
safer cleaner water for all Heidi pic
Global News Dartmouth Nova
Scotia the scars of War next the toll of
the Middle East crisis on Mental
[Music]
Health there is no easy way to explain
the horror of what's happening right now
in the Middle East the new cycle is
devastating
as are the images and the information
circulating around the globe as
Katherine Ward reports understanding
trauma under these circumstances is
critical and it may look different from
one person to the next and a warning to
our viewers this report contains images
that may be upsetting trauma distressing
events life-altering
circumstances and the Fallout that
pushes down on people with its emotional
weight people are being exposed to
atrocities War violence
conflict and and horrifying scenes
experts sometimes use the analogy of a
drop of water think about this idea of
trauma having a ripple effect across
Society it really can show up in
multiple different
places for those in the conflict Zone
day-to-day survival is Paramount I feel
the most vulnerable uh I've ever felt in
my life post-traumatic stress disorder
is a possible outcome being on guard on
Edge super aware of one's surroundings
can convey some type of survival
Advantage as the ripples extend the
trauma can look different our flight is
is cancelled um but we're staying calm
and we're confident that we will get
home and uh it's unfortunate
situation survivors guilt is potentially
something that many folks who experience
traumatic events especially those
involving death do experience there is
also the fear for loved ones and living
in the unknown know what's going on no
one's talking to us uh we can't get in
talk contact with anyone experts say
offering appropriate support is key Our
Hope would be that the families that are
fleeing from the conflict in the Middle
East right now are able to access some
of these Services once they arrive in
host countries the health impact also
extends to those watching events unfold
in media and online Katherine Ward
Global News Toronto we wanted to end the
news newscast with some uplifting news
Canadian break dancer Philip Kim has
danced his way into next year's Olympics
the 26-year-old from Vancouver also
known as Phil wizard captured gold and
break dancing at this year's
Pan-American games and with this win Kim
punched his ticket to Paris where break
dancing will make its debut as an
Olympic sport Kim is also been selected
as one of Canada's flag bearers for the
panm games closing ceremony and that's
global national for this Sunday night
I'm faren nower and on behalf of our
whole crew here I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your Sunday
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
atland British Columbia we love seeing
your Canada so please keep emailing us
those photos to viewers
global.com Donna we'll be back with you
tomorrow until we're together next time
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good
[Music]
night